there are many brave journalists across  the world who risk their lives to tell  the truth  in europe too journalists and media  often face threats political and  economic pressure and even violence are  happening far too frequently this is why  we are acting to protect media freedom  today we are breaking new ground we are  proposing the media freedom act  for the first time we are protecting in  law the editorial independence of the  media  no state interference  no turning public media into propaganda  of one party  better protection for journalists  against spying  no hacking of their phones and computers  more transparency  the public has the right to know who  owns and funds the media and how the  state uses funds to buy advertising  all this comes on top of our efforts to  improve the safety of journalists and  fight abusive litigation against them  i want the eu to be leading the fight  for democratic values  and the media freedom act is part of  this effort